- You might get a nipple
shot, but you can censor that.
(rock music)
- We're contouring my boobs.
Oh my God, this is like my greatest dream.
- I didn't know it was a thing.
I have too much boob.
- I am really excited because
I have very small boobs.
- I used to never be so
conscious about my boobs
until it was used as an insult.
- I think it's a lie.
- I hope I don't like this.
(rock music)
Already, this is more
makeup than I've ever owned.
- It looks like I'm supposed
to take a really dark color
and draw a big line.
- This is erotic.
- Right now it looks like chest hair.
or like a skid mark.
- Oh, you do a curve. I ****** up.
- Mine are so uneven.
- It looks like I'm
drawing a dick on my chest.
Look, it just...
- Nobody can touch you
if you've done this.
Give someone a hug and then like,
"Oh, sorry, those are my breasts."
- This is what guys imagine
girls do at sleepovers.
- Really titillated right now.
- Okay, so now I blend it.
Now this is where all of a sudden
it turns into Kim Kardashian.
- Wooh!
Okay, it looks worse than before.
- I kinda see it a little bit.
- This is what you want, world?
- Let me see if it jiggles the same.
- They're definitely lopsided
like this one's killing it right now.
- I painted my chest tan.
(rock music)
- Are you impressed with what I did?
- Impressed is a word.
- You're using red?
- I'm using a burgundy.
- Burgundy?
- So I picked the wrong color.
- The chest bleeding look?
- So special effects for your boobs.
(rock music)
- This makes me feel
like I'm going to be in
the Lion King actually.
I'm not kidding.
- Is this beautiful?
- See, look, now we're
getting that cleave thing?
- Oh yeah, check it out.
- Ooh, now it kind of looks like
that painting with the scream.
- Welcome to the makeup video,
"Everything's Fake and Everyone's a Liar."
- This takes too long for me
to ever do this on my own.
- So would you say this is
like an everyday affair?
Okay.
- This looks very natural, I can't lie.
(rock music)
- What do you think?
- What?
I'm like Barbie.
- Holy ****!
- I don't like it.
- This is everything they ever wanted.
- Oh man.
I've got makeup on my chest.
- The girls are out today.
- Now I'm unstoppable.
- I'm impressed.
It looks so natural and so decent.
However, this is not what I look like.
- Certainly reads as fake to me.
- I don't know if I'd ever
realistically do this,
but yeah, they look amazing.
- I had overexpectations.
- I mean, it's just accentuating
what's already there.
- This makes me feel
like I have on a mask.
- You know what they feel like
if I didn't have contoured boobs?
You probably might be able
to touch my boob later on the date
if you played your cards right.
- But I am trying to get to a
place where I accept my body
for what it is, and doing this seems like
the exact opposite of that.
- If this is the kind of thing
that you don't feel like
would inhibit you, rock it.
- I think it also showed me that
I have a perfect amount
to work with as it is.
- At the end of the day,
you should be doing it for yourself.
You know I made sure to
do before I came here
was do a quick scan of
the breast area and pluck
those little random
boob hairs that you get?
Do you get those?
Please, say people know
what I'm talking about.
- I know, people totally know
what you're talking about.
(rock music)